[Music]
all right thanks for joining us Louis
well I'm right down the block so this
was really oh great yeah we worked out
on all levels thanks good thank you well
thanks you do you look good that's weird
that's right did it look like on other
things you look better than you used to
look
that's what people say that's uh that's
one of the things that that thing where
people come up and go God you lost
weight right thanks so that was but a
beast yeah you [ __ ] I thought it was
okay and if I really needed to lose a
lot of weight and obviously was in
danger but why did you say something oh
wow I didn't know you then but Todd
Glass has that great joke about uh he's
like you ever have somebody tell you
look like somebody that's super
insulting like you look like John
Goodman but a thin John Goodman you look
like a good looking pig
that's a good one yeah it is
good the uh yeah no but thank you I've
been uh the uh the only thing about the
pandemic that was good to me was anxiety
really kind of helped oh yeah how did it
help you because I lost weight it's the
best dieting I mean I really did but you
know and what really irks is your doctor
my doctor said you know it'd be really
good if you lost you know 15 to 20
pounds and I lost more yeah okay and
then I uh and then the thing is is
you're supposed to one would think you
you know because he said one of the
great things that he said about it was
is that you know it's you know when
you're when you have 20 pounds extra and
you're but you're wandering around it's
like carrying 20 pounds on you sure it's
like carrying a [ __ ] beliefs with 20
pounds all day well I lost the weight
yeah and then I lost even more and then
I got back to see him then I go yeah
well that's a great concept I still feel
like I'm [ __ ] 30 pounds you don't
feel like I'm carrying it [ __ ] yeah
it didn't go away it don't it went away
and I still feel it so well that's
playing that that's just the stress on
your shoulders you got the anxiety what
what do you think is the the key to your
anxiety what causes it well no that was
it was the pandemic
really I'd never had anything about
every comic had anxiety no really no no
not every there's some Comics no there's
some I go in the LA green rooms there's
some Comics
yeah but I don't do tai chi yeah yeah
and I'm certainly not but there are a
lot of happy-go-lucky Comics yeah Cosby
was happy yeah he had a good time he
wasn't lucky yeah
exactly but uh now that guy uh I got
raped a lot of women yeah yeah
apparently no that's a big No-No that is
stealing jokes are the two things
I do I did realize it like you know
sometimes I'll get really pissed about a
comic stealing jokes and then you're
like well now I definitely got to speak
out if they rape you know I can't be the
guy who's only tweeting about that you
stole a joke yeah you're gonna be like
rape is bad too yeah I guess because No
One's Gonna rape us so the joke you
could steal my joke but you're not gonna
rape it so it's just selfish I'm pumped
to have you here because I've followed
your career forever I mean like I I used
to open for Dave Attell a lot he told me
about touring with you oh yes I mean the
tour was you and David tell were
co-headlining and the opening actors
wow yeah it was pretty remarkable that's
insane it was really insane and it was
also insane because David and I for some
reason become the the faces of Comedy
Central yes even even with the Daily
Show being on day the day Dave and I
would do these [ __ ] interstitials at
the end of the week they would have a
show like you know some bogus [ __ ] show
where they'd have six different Comics
yeah sort of [ __ ] sketches whatever
the [ __ ] and they'd have Dave and I
introduced this stuff so that we were
always kind of on yeah you know and he
was doing insomnia and I was doing the
daily a lot and all of a sudden they
said you want to do this to her [ __ ]
yeah hell yeah did he tell you about the
the great Jay Patel story oh I can't
wait it was one of the great ones was uh
we had we had a lot of fun and uh he was
still drinking oh God
he did one thing that was the most the
most brilliant thing I'd ever seen in
terms of dealing with we'd have to we'd
want to go out afterwards
so he would he would in our in the
writer he had him give him a bottle of
Jaeger yeah of course and I said Jesus
said you're going to get a bottle every
night that's crack you can't drink it
that much he should watch so we go to
the we go to the whatever we're going to
the bar and he walks up to the bar and
puts that bottle of Jager down slams it
down on the bar and goes drink up drinks
around us and then we would walk to the
back of the bar and they like [ __ ]
minnows would go
you know scatter and get up to the to
the bar and he and I could go on the
back and just basically not be bothered
wow that's brilliant it was really smart
but he one night we were I get I can't
for the life of me remember what [ __ ]
town we were in yeah but we he gets he
uh we go we I left the bar uh before him
and got back and he apparently walked
back to the hotel
and then got a cab he's got at his own
we're at the he's at his hotel yeah gets
a cab to go to his hotel ah he was that
[ __ ] up that's great yeah oh my God
how good is that I've done it before
with your [ __ ] faced and you use your
credit card to try to get on the subway
I've done that which now you can do yeah
right but back in the day you would try
to swipe like a Visa yeah yeah
but this was really something because he
he sent them to the uh to uh I think
it's of this and then he would name the
hotels and eventually he named the hotel
he was at and they drove back to the
hotel it was really Splendor it man it
made me feel so good about my blind you
know shit-faced drinks right right I
thought wow I've been [ __ ] up but I
didn't do that yeah I mean I'm almost
scared to ask but how was Mitch Mitch
was just Mitch was Mitch yeah here's
Mitch Mitch is
um uh we uh the first day we're going to
Austin we're in a van we go get up we
hop out in one of these places we're
picking up some gas and it's and there's
a whole bunch of these red Solo cups
there
and uh he goes up with about 12 of them
huh to the guy and he says how much can
I buy these and the guy goes yeah I'm
gonna try that and he gives him some
money and he he comes out beaming with
these 12 red Solo cops going he said you
know God you know you you know you
you're never gonna you know you never
and you never know when you're gonna you
need one of these and I just went wow we
are in that I thought this is going to
be one of the strangest here
that was it you think he was [ __ ] up I
he must have been well if he's not it's
then it's the dementia yeah then
something poor boyish excitement yeah I
mean it's like well I mean those red
Solo cups I thought you know you live in
Minneapolis right say you were born and
raised there I know they have Rich
you know you can't be trying to impress
Dave and I no we've seen those [ __ ]
cups right right I guess those cups
equal a good time it's like a party or a
Barbie
but he was he was very funny and he and
he was there for but we had said at the
beginning that uh you know that we were
not Dave and I both made it very clear
you are not expecting us
to be in charge of him oh wow you know
yeah you cannot ask Dave and I who are
going who are going to go to the bar
right and gonna be [ __ ] up to be in
charge of the other this is like a
hangover movie right here totally I just
throwing heroin that's the only
difference was he was he soberish on the
on the road with you guys or no well I
mean the first day it was one of those
things where you get your
um you know you have your Rider and you
know when we'd never had none of us you
know we'd all wear clubs we never had a
rider so it was like I'll get a I got a
I got a vodka they've got the the uh
Jaeger and Mitch got a bottle of vodka
and it was like
um and he was supposed to be in a
sobriety thing so it was kind of like
Damon I looked at each other and went oh
okay well okay well that's that yeah you
know this is not this is not my book
we're gonna have to call the guys again
and say you know we're not and he he got
a bottle of vodka each night yeah for a
while and then I don't remember because
I mean I literally okay a bottle of
vodka tonight what happens is by the
third night you go I got two and a half
bottles of vodka right yeah exactly
exactly stupid yeah well you got those
Solo cups yeah you gotta fill them up uh
can I can ask though like back in the
day I feel like in Comedy Central they
used to air all these tours I remember
seeing your tour with David tell and
Hedberg and I saw the Geraldo one then
you'd have tour guide they used to put
these on TV I don't feel like we do that
anymore do we no no comedies tours no no
what they do now is then they get which
just goes back to before that when
they'd get four people and they go
tonight is you know here's the the best
of the the best of the scooters yeah
here come the scooters and these these
these are every comic who talks about
scooters where I have mine tonight and
there'll be four you know they just do
it you know package it they package it's
not a long yeah it's yeah it's not the
uh the way that you know they did they
and they only really did some of that
yeah you know I feel like being a comic
at that time was so rock and roll like
so much of Comedy a lot of comics seem
to be going through a health phase but
you were in this time when it was like
you're Dr you're drinking a towel's
drinking hedberg's doing God knows what
yeah you know and I think of those
stories I remember I don't know if it
was in your book or in Jim Norton's book
I read about you guys getting arrested
oh yeah it was Jordan and I oh let's
hear it oh yeah well that's the one it's
the the uh that's um it was the naked
party bus I can't remember what they
call the goddammit there was a name for
it and it was we were doing
um Opie and Anthony oh right Jim was
starting to become part of that group
but it hadn't reached that you know
hadn't been brought on right as a
regular I was on there at least once
every 10 days yeah wow and it was great
they were on in the afternoons and and I
was really comfortable and Anthony and I
would just scream at each other yeah
just great he was so full of [ __ ] and he
thought I was so full of [ __ ] and we
just battle with each other and there
was no and it's this whole thing of now
we live in a Great Divide he and I were
on a Great Divide but neither of us took
it seriously right both of us knew that
we were heat you know we were full of
[ __ ] yeah so you know I'm yelling at him
he's telling me then they say we've got
these uh we got a bus coming today and
uh there's gonna be uh these we'd gotten
these girls they're supposed to be these
uh these these girls are going to be uh
naked on the bus and did Jim and I want
to go on the bus well you [ __ ] yeah
you know and it was and it never crossed
my mind if they go teenage and this
still is not registering until later uh
when um but we we get on the bus and the
boy
it was called the Boyer bus and the deal
was is they were driving around the
country and there was one girl who was
in it at that point I think there may
have been two of them but one at that we
could come to New York and they drove
around the whole idea as you drove
around a city in order to
um to express our the our first
amendment rights
because that's right really isn't that
like something you think the first thing
you think of is take naked girls around
and that's our first amendment now are
they attractive because sometimes these
first amendment gals can be a little
rough around the edge
I know what you're thinking but no oh
right no it was really uh but but it's
also the way to express your freedom of
speech I think is your tits yeah exactly
but it's also the same I I said at the
time that we were doing it it's like
saying you know you don't yell fire in
the theater it's like saying the
equivalent of saying well don't yell
[ __ ] you in a theater right that's you
know that's I mean come on guys the
First Amendment just say it for what it
is yeah whatever it is that you're
trying to sell let's go sell it and yeah
thank you for inviting me on the bus yes
now did the Santa send this bus up here
this was back when when when things were
fun yeah those were the days remember
when this was not a political statement
oh my God these breasts are making no
statement whatsoever except to the to
the Delight of Norton and me and there
was another producer and and along the
way we picked up a friend of mine who
was the artistic director of a theater
that I did a lot of work at in the
Summers I said you know he was married
and I said I think you're going to want
to do this yeah and so he hopped on the
bus you're his wife's least favorite
friend it yeah and here's a big one it's
uh you know who Kate Burton is I don't
know you don't really wow that's great I
can't wait I can't wait to tell her it's
Richard Burton's daughter oh okay and a
really fine actress it's her husband
isn't her isn't his son an actress actor
too uh yes he's uh but she's the one and
uh well who's who's Richard Burton's son
because he's also famous isn't he uh
rich I don't know I know her but what I
really know and I know her husband
really will so I got him on the bus now
we're driving around and the whole where
it's just before Christmas okay so we're
driving all over we're driving we're
coming right down [ __ ] uh you know
right down Ninth Avenue right down
[ __ ] ninth coming from the uh the
where the we were on 56th street we spin
out of there come down and we moved
through the city like a bat out of hell
oh yeah and these girls are standing
there and then we would roll up and
they'd be we'd be sitting there these
guys would be looking up and these girls
are standing there kind of doing a
little bit of a dancing going yeah
that's right go [ __ ] your subs you
pieces of [ __ ] so that's what they're
saying the whole thing was just
magnificent of course because they are
getting back at them they think they're
getting the show and meanwhile what's
extraordinary is these old ladies who
were the ones who think their thumbs up
yeah yeah they're like couldn't be
happier nobody bothered it's Christmas
you [ __ ] idiots everybody is happy
here comes a bus filled with tits yes
who could complain so we go all the way
around now we've gotten a around at
[ __ ] four o'clock 3 34 4 30. so we're
getting into rush hour and we're moving
like about out of hell and we get
through the city in 40 minutes wow well
you get out of the way for tits you got
it the lanes open up and they and and
the cops who would listen to Opie
Anthony because the cops weren't stupid
we're always on top of the fact that if
if they were going to do something
idiotic they need to kind of have to
deal with it right so so that they knew
they had to help us get through and they
did and there was no sense of traffic
being [ __ ] up spectacular yeah we're
up with three blocks from the studio we
dropped my friend off he's so [ __ ]
lucky he got out of that bucket he gets
off we drive three more blocks we're
three blocks away from where we have to
be and the cops stop us
and and basically drag take us off the
bus they put us in in those [ __ ] up
handcuffs those plastic cases the zip
ties and they took all of us including
the girls everybody really everybody get
off the bus with and it's because at
that point Rudy Giuliani was the mayor
in New York and he was going to be sure
he said that we were disturbing there it
is it's my friend and he said we were
going to be disturbing the peace
come on man it was like [ __ ] you and it
was also here's the it was like it's
always amazing how this [ __ ] that's the
most honest thing you can say yeah it's
funny so why did we why did they also
take us off the street because within an
hour and a half later an hour and a half
Max I mean probably
um he was coming through was uh Bill
Clinton who's who was the president at
that point sure so he's coming through
so we're basically being busted he's
gotten a [ __ ] we're getting busted
for being on this bus yeah we and you're
not you and we're not breaking the law
because why in New York City uh women
can be topless that's right yeah so the
whole thing was Madness well Bill
Clinton did was worse yeah yes getting
your dick sucked by your employee in the
Oval Office is worse than a titty bus in
Midtown yeah it is it would seem to be
he should he should have waited a lot
longer to get by or they should have
told them the bus was coming through
would you like to join
it was really something I mean it was
one of those things and then they took
us and we were in jail for a day and a
half wow wow a day and a half yeah well
we they took us in yeah no they took us
in that night
we had a gig no I not that I remember
there was no mug shots because they we
didn't even get that far we went in we
had just we stayed there and then if Jim
would remember and then I can't remember
the next day
um we had to get we we had to be Tried
by uh that by a certain time and if and
if we weren't that we'd be there the
whole weekend so this was like a
Thursday I think when we got caught we
go in there in the evening and then and
then they put us into genpop which is a
general population so now we're sitting
in there Jim and I Jim at that time as
much as Jim would talk a good ball game
or I could certainly go go [ __ ] yourself
pretty easily if we're like going huh
yeah this has gone too far and then
we're going you know I think maybe I
said did anybody card those girls did
anybody card the girls did anybody card
the girls that's all we need Jim yeah
we're gonna have we're gonna get busted
for this is now we're going to get
busted for being on a bus with topless
girls God damn it and they're underage
we're [ __ ] oh no so that's also you're
next you're next to Jeffrey Epstein in
the cell he's like I got the I got their
age I think they're good yeah and I was
in and the boot I was in Jeffrey
Epstein's uh house once what really yes
with Bobby Slayton I've got nothing yeah
when they got up to go to the bathroom
did he smell the seeds
no how about how is Jeffrey Epstein's
house unbelievable I mean but what was
the occasion Bobby Slayton I
um Woody Allen and SUNY oh my God this
is like a Mad Libs
holy moly it is that's a very good one
that's nice man there was um Dick Cavett
wow wow and not I can't think of his
name I can see him Harvey nope not a
good guy but he throws a hell of a
dinner party yeah
but it was and then there was one other
comic and I can't remember she's passed
away correct and it's another one Louis
Anderson Norm Bob Zagat Gilbert nobody
will reach okay I mean it's one further
back it's he's he's I know everybody's
married not Richard Jenny no Freddie
Roman Allen King no no we could we could
play it sounds like Okay
um
uh and he he was and I can tell you this
he was married to Thai Babylonia all
right that's all you need Ty babylonia's
husband yeah and I can't think of you
how do you get invited to Epstein's if
[ __ ] Slayton called me up and said uh
we you know he really likes
um Comics Randy Gardner no that's a
figure skater no all right blind boy
Tano
[Laughter]
yeah he was a middle act
so yeah what's the occasion for this it
was that Bobby had gotten us he had
invited a bunch of you know Epstein was
like uh-huh let's go you know let's get
a bunch of who has together I mean if
you looked at the list of people he hung
out with so he liked Bobby's work and
then he said he liked he he wanted to
meet me apparently but Bobby because
he's got really unbelievable wine we're
gonna drink really I said okay [ __ ] it I
know nothing about him
it's yeah it's David Brenner David
Brenner yeah okay David Legend wow and
he was really funny his place for wine
yeah so all those bottles 16 years
so I may nothing is this is years ago
this is way this is like seven years
before the the [ __ ] hits the van oh yeah
and we're there and I'm
and it was just kind of wild and then
the the Capper of the evening is at the
very end David Blaine shows up whoa oh
yeah can you make these charges
disappear
so he uh that was our that was our night
we and I'll tell you
um there were young girls
flitting about but I didn't know
having having not figured out anything
on the boy or bus about age I had no
idea I didn't know that how old or young
they were sure and there was a woman who
uh who was an older woman who's really
really attractive and I and I thought
she
I thought she was the one yeah that was
Epstein's you know girlfriend that's
what I thought uh and uh and it was the
kind of thing you go into is you when we
got here here's what's it's weird from
the beginning because it's like uh you
go in and he's got a white board and
there's all of this stuff drawn on it
and he goes you want me to tell you what
that is and I go yeah well sure Bobby
and I he goes you know I had the Israeli
defense minister here last night for
dinner and then he's got me and Bobby
Slayton [ __ ] are you [ __ ] me and
then he said and so we were talking
about he was showing me what kind of
defense system
Israel would use in case of attack wow
and I thought you know what first of
what is the Israeli defense minister
what the [ __ ] is the matter why would
you tell me this is already now it's
weird yes nothing else is weird but I
know this was like a honk honk something
is wrong in this house yeah this is a
guy who's working on his defense many
years before
right that's interesting I mean and this
place was outstanding right I mean it
was just yeah it was gorgeous yeah you
can see it was it up or west it's upper
no it's upper it's between Madison and
fifth oh okay nice in mid 60s and it
kind of is like a big you know it was a
big and it didn't have a lot of
furniture in it was very bare but you
know but it was yeah but it looked it
was done well yes and the wine was
stupidly expensive and uh yeah it was it
was a great wine but it was really great
can you tell when you're like having I
can't really tell but I can't because
that's my that's it's just another way
to hide your house
right you can go boy now I can take I
have a sense now of what's good yes I'm
a connoisseur not an alcoholic yeah
exactly that's how they were in Kentucky
all week and they're like so proud that
they're like these bourbon sommeliers
but I'm like you're still a good job you
can tell that there are caramel notes
you're still wrapping your car around
the [ __ ] pole you know yeah exactly
heroin addicts know when it's pure [ __ ]
yeah versus
but it was really um
and we got invited back again ah and
Bobby said you want to go I said ain't
going to that house again oh really yeah
no absolutely not I don't care how good
the wine is I said something is [ __ ]
up in there and I don't know what it is
you know no this thing it's the thing
where somebody wants to hang out with
you and they may be able to give you
something right but you go I don't
[ __ ] I don't want it it feels weird
then you're indebted to them yeah
Bobby's like we're getting massages
what uh did you know Woody Allen while I
remember you were in Hannah and Her
Sisters yeah it's a great movie great
movie it turned his career around one of
one of his best I think I agree top
three
I think it's the first movie you made
money off of and I said and I'm the only
person in it who really brought it over
there
it was it was I had a good time working
with them I mean I really here's
something I mean if I I don't know if
you guys have ever done a movie but
here's the smart thing he taught us it
was me and a guy named Christian Clemens
who did a bunch of Television afterwards
and films and we were doing our first
scene this first scene I've ever done in
a movie uh-huh and you must have been
[ __ ] bricks I mean this is
terrifying Woody Allen this is your
opening movie yeah it was I was and it
was really and uh and I I kind of could
[ __ ] with him because I've been in
theater so I had and I knew his work in
terms of theater and stuff because he'd
been so I could [ __ ] with him on that
level I said you know because there's
all this [ __ ] on there and then we're
gonna go do this scene and I and we we
shot the first scene we shot it we were
going to rehearse and we did it and we
got back in and there had been a bunch
of [ __ ] ups and I said oh I guess I
guess this is you know you wanted to do
this instead of theater yeah and uh and
he he didn't really laugh but I thought
okay well at least I gave it a shot
and we and we did and then he said okay
we're gonna rehearse it again and then
we said we got one more and we'll get
the cameras right we did it again and
then once we did it again he said that
we got it and let's move on he said I
want you to think of everything that
we're doing is a rehearsal oh
interesting keep you loose it was and
that that was huge wow yeah because you
realized oh [ __ ]
you know I didn't think about it I
didn't worry about it and I still to
this day I will try to use that but you
still they go roll them and you still
tighten up that's good but it's a great
it really is one of the few lessons I
had in my life in terms of just
basically dealing with a camera that in
in terms of film because you sometimes
run it for three minutes five minutes
whatever if you don't think of it as
like something that's got to be done and
just think of it as we're just doing it
yeah that's good your Woody Allen joke
was too soon
he's not a guy you seem like you can
really you don't picture like the roast
of Woody Allen you're roasting David
Hasselhoff
what's funny was it was how
that he's outside of that set I I he
doesn't seem to be he's more introverted
on the side oh yeah on the set he's that
guy yeah right that's when he is that
guy and um and he's a very good director
and the um and the kids were around yeah
and uh I didn't you know I'm the one who
goes I don't I you know that was the
weird thing is I didn't notice anything
the kids seem to be what do I know yeah
yeah because you know people jock you
who's you work for them you son of a
[ __ ] what that [ __ ] was like you know
what are you [ __ ] doing yeah what was
that 92 or something yeah and and uh and
I still I could go through the whole
history of it and it's we'll do that on
the next one
will you bring me back for Woody part
two oh yeah Epstein part three
and whatever did happen at the uh inside
the jail what was interesting though to
get back to that was after that after
they took Norton and I we went in when
we once we got to the [ __ ] because we
had to be out of there yeah now it's
like eight o'clock and they've got till
like 8 30 or something and they're
they're bringing the first group and the
judge goes are you [ __ ] kidding me I
mean basically it was a female judge who
said I you've got to be kidding me she
said all the things going on in New York
City at this point in time just before
Christmas that you are really going to
tell me that you want me to try these
people all right and keep them in check
what is the matter with you you know
what planet are you on nothing bad
happened it was fine and they got two
and a half and here here and and they
got the first before the next four in
the next four we all were like we were
out of there and when we got up it was
like stop yeah just really go get out of
here damn it's a different time because
just think about being on that bus now
everybody would have phones out and all
this would be recorded and then even the
jail stuff you're like I gotta get
content to get the trials you take your
phone yeah I know I'm just saying like
it's just a better time when you could
just live yeah now everything is
recorded and filmed there's much more
freedom for sure yeah there was a lot I
mean it was really it would and it was
funny and it was just silly and it was
Goofy and then they tried to get us and
it's like you know you're talking to
Norton and I were paranoid enough that
you've got in turn Journal Affairs there
you're trying to bust the cops who have
become now I you know become because of
that [ __ ] show all the cops know who
I am oh great so it was like these are
people you don't [ __ ] boy you don't [ __ ]
with my friendship [ __ ] idiot anybody
you kidding me you're gonna come here
and investigate the cops who got all
these people through yeah all they did
was do their job properly and you're
seeing it as a crime [ __ ] you here here
that's one thing I'll say about cops
they love comedy I got my moped stolen
recently and I went to go they found it
and I went to go pick it up and they
were like we've heard you are you on
open air are you on this and that I was
like yeah they were all going nuts it
was great yeah no it is it makes it they
they listen to it oh yeah and they're
and they're great yeah they need a they
need a laugh yeah a lot a lot more now
yeah yeah yeah
yeah so have you been on the road a lot
I just started hey this I had to I was
so pissed because I had to stop you
pissed get out of here
because I I was I did my I did I went
from December to May 15th and May 15th I
did a new special oh and then and then
because everybody was using because all
of these people were trying to get back
into theaters yeah they couldn't get
back in until they had to push stuff
that I did until uh till until this uh
till now yeah I'm kind of you know still
cleaning up the stuff that I hadn't done
before so sure I went I was on the road
and did New England and then I go to uh
Warren Ohio this week and tomorrow and I
quit bragging yeah I know you're kidding
me I don't even know where that is I
don't either it's uh it's it's near it's
near Akron and uh kind of near Cleveland
okay and then on to Dayton there you go
Carmel Indiana I know that please get a
pen get a pen
and uh if you build your hour back up
tour
so I gotta say you know I'm a fan I've
been watching for years did you know and
you probably do know this but George
Carlin was interviewed years ago and he
said who do you like they said who do
you like you know coming up and he said
you and Hedberg yeah it was unbelievable
I mean what a yeah what a it was you tip
of the cap and it was huge for me
because nobody knew me oh really no I I
literally was just on The Daily Show for
two years maybe I was just starting to
get known but not I was playing clubs
and uh wandering around and I had
I don't even know if I had my first CD
out wow and then you were crushing in
the clubs I heard I heard like you were
a dude that when I was even like I mean
you had been this is you were further
established at this point but people
would say like Lewis used to crush like
stand up New York all those lows it was
fun to do yeah it was really fun and it
was fun to and I missed in a way I
really do miss uh being in that lineup
of like with Gaffigan or Kevin beanie or
uh
Mario Cantona I mean the people who I
was in the lineups with were it was just
fun yeah you know you and Mario can't
tell them back to back it's a fun show
imagine I'd be standing there screaming
about Reagan at the top of my lungs and
then and then Mario would follow me yeah
and uh and that was what was great too
none of us had any we all got such a
kick out of it it wasn't like you were
competing with somebody he was like
great great now I get to follow that
great this would be good because the
room is really bouncing around and Mario
wouldn't be on the stage they'd
introduce him and then he in the corner
after I just come off would start
singing uh uh as Tina Turner What's Love
Got to Do with it and he would sing that
song all the way onto the stage so now
the whole [ __ ] now the room's going
crazy for another reason I love it and I
saw the best uh
they don't do it I don't know if they do
it anymore where they come in somebody
comes in from like Network or from
Comedy Central to watch you how do that
[ __ ] go on uh so they would they were
coming in to see Kevin Meaney it was um
I forget the the show it was uh it was
one that John Candy had done the movie
and and and Kevin was going to be on the
TV show and they were coming in to look
at him okay it was ABC and he
he did a thing called We are the world
yes it's really just spectacular that
was his signature bit it was his
signature bit and it was right at the
point where he had it perfected and I
I'm following him yeah and they're all
there to watch him and and the thing to
me was always in terms of that it was
there was always an inordinate amount of
you know you're gonna go from you know
eating [ __ ] gruel yes to eating gruel
with nuts
but it's just a rehearsal
you know but he got up there and crushed
it was one of the most extraordinary
auditions because I'd seen the piece 17
20 30 times and I was like holy how did
he find you know that thing where you go
how did they find the next level
and I and the audience went berserk yeah
berserk I love it and then I had to
follow him oh geez and I walked on stage
and I said
um
you have no desire to see me
so here's what we're gonna do we're
gonna take some time right now to just
admire how [ __ ] funny he is you gotta
do that how good this bit was and you
know what I'm going to do I'm going to
sit down and when you're done I'll get
up and talk to you
it was great yeah well done and they
went on for like but they went on for
like seven minutes it was great I did I
remember we used to do the competitions
in New York called March Madness and it
was like comic versus comic I called it
uh Eight Mile for Jews
you go head to head against another
comic you know you're a minute versus
their minute then it would go up to like
four minutes versus their four minutes
and I went against this comic James
matter and uh it was unbelievable at
crowd work unreal so he goes up there
and I just have to watch him just
[ __ ] eviscerate just the room is on
fire he's just going look at this guy
and look at this just murdering I'm like
I can't follow this because
so I I just had to go up and I said I
can't do that and it got a huge laugh
and that kind of like saved me I'm just
being like I can't do what he did and uh
and then and it took a minute they all
kind of applauded and then I was able to
go into my jokes yeah it was like but
you do have to acknowledge yes or you
just get buried yeah you gotta I mean
that's the thing that I never understood
and you see it all the time where you
got that [ __ ] idiot on stage and the
audience hates them yes and they're
acting
you know that they're missing the point
I called the Dale Carnegie School of
Comedy uh-huh where they're just you
know couldn't be happier with the [ __ ]
that they're doing yeah and it drives me
[ __ ] nuts and there's no connection
at all no connection so I don't I never
understand how you how you don't
recognize that and say I mean when I've
when I've hit the [ __ ] when I was
first working and hitting the [ __ ] I
was cut I would make jokes about it sure
yeah you know I I would lie down I would
say what I'm going to do now I think you
I think it's seeing me that's bothering
you I'm gonna lie down on the stage you
know whatever it took dude but you have
to acknowledge it you have to and that's
something you only get from just doing
reps and and actually bombing every now
and then yeah exactly and and and and
being able and see that you can get
comfortable yeah I have a question for
you because I saw you I think it was on
CNN it was many years ago it must have
been like honestly like close to 15
years ago so I don't remember the exact
context of this but you were on with a
bunch of politicians and you were just
being money and they we're asking you
serious questions about policy and at
one point you went I'm a comedian yes
like why are you asking me this and I do
feel like
because now like not every comic they
weren't always this political not every
comic of course feels political now so
much feels
you have to have a take on everything
yeah I guess my question is basically
like
did you feel like they were like what
are they doing like what is this you
know like why are they going to you for
those types of answers when we're we're
not in this for that no you know and I
stopped going on the shows oh good I
said you know um I'm going I'm going to
go on as a comic and you're going to
talk to me as a comic and that's it I'm
not here I'm not getting you you're not
gonna push me in the position of being
um uh you know a commentator you're not
going to push me into a position of some
an editorialist I'm not yeah I'm
sticking with my comedy and so I [ __ ]
and and
Ben Stein oh yeah I was on a show with
him and there are a bunch of others I
made a joke about uh Schwarzenegger the
fact that he's uh he was running for
governor was governor of California and
I said something affected you know Jews
never never really trusted austrians and
I can't remember what the kind yeah it's
a stupid joke it was a Jewish joke that
was you know and it and it's a funny and
I done it before and it's a funny joke
and the people there left but Ben Stein
went well you know that Arnold has given
a lot of money to just shut up come on
[Music]
come
on
do you think I said Arnold's why don't
you call him tonight and tell him I said
the joke okay what is the matter with
you Ben geez and he's he's a comedy guy
yeah but not if anyone shouldn't trust
him with his wife I mean that's uh
all of them
it is amazing how articulate Arnold
could be where you'd watch him and you
know he's giving these like he gave that
speech about you know the night of the
broken glasses and you're like wow he's
so articulate and interesting and then
he's just like grabbing ashes as they
walk by yeah I mean it's really an
amazing yeah it's unbelievable yeah he's
a Charming guy yeah
he's an A-list movie they know how to
charm you yeah he'll be back
but yeah Jon Stewart said the same thing
he was on I think Tucker Carlson this is
yeah 12 15 years ago and they were like
what the hell John he's like I go on
after puppets yeah you know I'm a I'm a
comedy guy yeah it's a jokey show it's
but everybody now feels the need to to
they have to have an opinion yeah really
an opinion is easier than writing a
punchline you get more retweets being
like this is an outrage yeah just
writing an observational joke exactly
you know I mean seriously I think so I
think because that's the top I mean
because I find it
um I find it I I always get irritated
when I get which happens because I get
I've been up there and I'm like
bellowing like a lunatic and I don't
really have a punchline I'm still trying
to find the pit and I'll finish and they
all go you know yeah
and you go no no no I that and all all
that reminds me of yeah yeah you gotta
find now you gotta [ __ ] think about
this again I gotta find a lab somewhere
I know did they applaud at the end of a
series of punch lines it's like an
acknowledgment they like the bit that's
fine but they applaud just because they
agree you're like yes who gives a [ __ ]
yeah clapped her yeah yeah it's a very
it's true it's weird it's weird it's
more of an agreeance show than a comedy
show yeah it's weird when they do it in
like you'll be in like New York City and
some guys like I think gay should be
allowed to get married you're like it's
Manhattan dude yeah right like what this
isn't an edgy take
you see anything like a you know Pro Roe
v Wade you better have a [ __ ] good
punchline if you're doing that in the
western yeah tell me why you don't think
gay should get married now or listening
yeah that's comedy like I want to hear
that take yeah really there's six good
jokes there
there are I mean I forget who it was it
was the first time you know the first
one who did the joke and there were
probably 10 people in the country during
the you know that said you know the gay
thing is is like you know really let him
get married right you want to suffer you
fox yeah I don't know what suffering is
they have no idea exactly this is what
they wanted you know you and there's 500
variations of course Fran Liebowitz said
that and everything look she was like
you guys want to gays want to get in the
military and get married what the [ __ ]
are we doing yeah really and it's really
I mean good it's it's sitting there
that's that's where you go and then you
might go further with it yeah but then
there's people who have no sense of
humor going wait so you don't think so
you're homophobic you're like wait how'd
you get homophobic I'm like I'm trying
to get a rise out of you yeah I know I
and I get I have to know but I go right
now but I'm in the part of it is is
basically punching both sides yeah it's
like you're kind of going okay you
[ __ ] left the idiots over there and
then I'm punching over here at the right
and then I gotta punch the lip you know
because that woke [ __ ] is I mean it's
Madness yeah it's it's exactly you know
they meet right they don't have any clue
that they meet right here it is bad for
comedy I mean it really is bad I
think I believe it'll pass it'll pass I
think it'll pass but you guys are
getting [ __ ] thank you on the horse's
mouth
appreciate it looking for something
different to cover up that hole in your
wall this plate is that cool new metal
poster that you'll want in every room
they have millions of cool designs
available featuring gaming movies comics
and Anime displayed also features
officially licensed designs including
Star Wars Netflix and many more uh lots
of cool stuff you can get on this site
it only takes 20 seconds to hang a
display no power tools needed no damages
no frustrations you know I'm a very
irritable person I have no uh housing
skills so this comes in handy once you
mount one you can switch out a new plate
in a Flash with everyone that you buy
disc plate plants a tree
click the link in our description to see
some of our favorite displates and save
up to 29 get 25 off when you buy one or
two and 29 off when you buy three or
more discounts will automatically be
applied to your cart when you click the
link or use code drunk when you visit
display.com that's display.com code
drunk or click that link in our show
notes God Bless America and God bless
sheath underwear Mark's wearing them
right now I'm I'm saving them for the
weekend Keith underwear keeps your balls
off your leg it's hot as hell out there
the idea for sheath came from its
founder US Army soldier Robert Patton
during his second tour in Iraq this is
this is a real Patriot here and a nice
guy if it worked for him it'll work for
you I wear sheath underwear they're
great you do too oh yeah I look forward
to wearing them there's your you know
there's your pairs you're like and then
there's your sheets and you're like yeah
I'm gonna look true support the show
support this awesome veteran-owned
company go to sheathunderwear.com use
promo code drunk and get 20 off your
first order every order comes with
sheath 100 money back guarantee that's
sheathunderwear.com promo code drunk get
sheath underwear and let them support
your ball bag hell yeah
who you are I mean it really is it's
[ __ ] well we we pushed through but
yeah it's just a it's like a Nat or
you're like all right come on get out of
the way it'll it is cool to see Live
Comedy now more than ever because it
does have almost like a Prohibition Vibe
right well you're in the club and you're
like this is the place we can say it you
know I was doing these jokes about the
queen in in Louisville and they're
killing and I'm like I can't say this
[ __ ] on any show yeah no show will let
me let say these jokes right but in in a
club they're love they were loving them
too much to the point where all right
guys I mean she is dead go easy
like [ __ ] that [ __ ] I'm like [ __ ]
they were getting pretty man like I mean
but this is why comedy's so popular
right now live comedy is we are in a
huge boom because I think it's like the
Jimmy Fallon's of the world I was on
found recently and my best joke got cut
because it involved Amber Heard or
something I can't hear what I said or
involve Biden or something and I'm like
ah we don't know like oh so you're
you're out on Comedy we're more
concerned with being likable than funny
yes death to funny death I mean I did
The Daily Show yesterday and I I had a
great time my best laugh got cut and I'm
like you were scared to put this in
there and it killed for your crowd I
know what you did it what I did it
yesterday oh you did it yeah and my best
joke I cut no [ __ ] that's the state of
the industry today and I'm sure they
weren't online I'm sure they were like
we don't want to deal with the pushback
sure but it wasn't a malicious joke but
but I can tell that they were nervous
what was the joke the joke was okay
so we'll cut this later
I'd be sure to cut it before I send it
out to my social media people
they could have been nicer when I was
there and I want to preface I don't know
who cut it or why they cut it but I said
uh we were doing a bunch of talk about
trans jokes and I had a joke go viral
with you know the trans world for being
a pro trans joke so that's I think why
it caught steam because you know yeah
there are a lot of pro trans jokes out
there so then I had a thing where this
blogger came after like all these people
like this is our guy and I was kind of
like slowed down I don't want to be your
guy whatever and I'm I'm just nervous I
don't want any responsibility I'm just a
comic you know and this one blogger who
tried to ruin my career in 2013
basically said uh he made this horrible
joke in 2013 he's a bad person I [ __ ]
you not she's now a man look at that and
I said you were you were a woman in
2013. it's not possible that I'm a
better man
I got an Applause break on the show and
they and they cut it and I was kind of
like oh man that was my that was my like
biggest pop of the show so it was a
bummer but you know I don't know the
reasons they cut these things and we're
doing stand-up I wasn't doing standing
there was an interview you know and and
travel oh that's great and Trevor could
have been nicer and more and more
gracious and and I don't know that's
great yeah talk about YouTube check it
out yeah no I will I'll watch it that's
great but that joke got cut that's a
[ __ ] funny joke that's weird that's
my issue that's my fear with kind of the
wokeness and the well it's it's not
based on fact
stuff that's why I'm sure I'm sure he
gets well what do they do I mean they
will they've I've watched him yell about
stuff and yeah and I've been I bet it
wasn't him I better talk to him I bet it
wasn't him who did it and it could have
been it could have been Comedy Central
of course I would imagine but I'm sure
they didn't want to deal with it that's
all it is yeah no I'm sure it was Comedy
Central because it's just so because
they've Trevor's been caught on certain
things where they you're not caught he
is one of the most supportive of comics
that I've ever met yeah he's a real cop
he's a he's a great dude yeah no he gets
it I don't think it was him no no I
can't imagine I think it was some scared
producer who was like I don't want to
deal with it and it wouldn't be a
producer there it's somebody Comedy
Central because they will step in and do
their you know look at it it's it's the
uh we got you know it's that's it it's
that and nothing there's hardly anything
on this [ __ ] station I know I know
but it's they don't realize that that's
the reason that it's failing like like
the Emmys this year was like the lowest
rate it ever yeah Jimmy Kimmel does some
you know [ __ ] joke it was very
innocuous and he got called a racist and
a clan member and all this and you're
like this is why no one's watching the
problem is these shows already seem out
of touch and then you throw that on top
of it right they're dead of course they
want to watch a podcast where you know
nothing's cut it's just people talking
like of course that's the popularity of
podcasts and I still like the idea of
shows where you do an interview for a
crowd because you have to turn it on you
have to be funny yeah and that's the
cameras I love that but yeah
but that's a good one yeah but and
Trevor is easier I think probably to
have done it with he didn't do it wasn't
a lot of setup
joke stuff was there no it was just a
conversation exactly because that's what
drives me nuts when I do those things is
that you know now we're going to go over
what yeah
what you can just say Byron Allen can't
we just talk yeah I know right I don't
understand it it was when I was born
when I literally was a kid that's what
they did there were people
like uh uncertain shows Jack Parr which
is the you know legendary way back yeah
but he'd have somebody on the show
literally in the course of a year 100
times wow and they were on the show for
specifically the person for the for what
you were talking about and what you guys
do here they were on the show for
conversation yeah I like I watched an
old Tom Snyder interview with Jerry
Seinfeld and Tom Snyder is such a great
interviewer yeah like he did a it was so
different than what you see it was
almost like more like a podcast
than a show it was it was pretty good
and the one thing and I did like uh was
when uh Ferguson was on when I I did it
we got along immediately really well and
and and uh he so the second time it came
on he literally took the card and put it
in front of me went oh and ripped it and
then he just started talking and what
we'd and what you found out in those
conversations is much more interesting
of course then I don't want to sit there
and go you know and I I'm not when I was
in the movie with two weasels and it was
really it's gonna be spectacular and I
love the weasels [ __ ] you right he would
we were talking about living in the East
Village then got down to the specific
bar we would go to then realized we were
both at the same [ __ ] part the same
[ __ ] time wow and he was a raging
this is when he had really made the
switch he wasn't gonna drink anymore
this is when I said I was going into
high gear and so we were at the same and
then sit there and discover that we're
in the same neighborhood at the same
time and drinking at the same bar and
didn't see each other because that's how
[ __ ] drunk we are wow you can't beat
that no no yeah we met at Epstein's
so yeah coincidence but yeah that's the
way to do it real conversation and
that's why TV is kind of feels like it's
fizzling out a little but you were on
like a golden age like that Daily Show
lineup you were on is epic I mean that
was like it was you Corel yeah yeah who
else was on it was that Helms on that
one too the Helms came on later after
after Corel left it was the towel on
when you were there huh was David tell
on when you were gave it to everyone
because they were all on because I was
on from the very I was on from the first
week wow wow I'm the longest I'm the
Andy brunia that yeah
just in terms of longevity I just think
I just uh you know and I I went to
everybody I mean being there with and
when Corel and Colbert and me uh
remember Beth Beth Littleford yeah she
was yep she was our Wyatt I was terrific
Jason and uh but coron Colbert was in
Asif was he was terrific uh I um
the the advanced DeGeneres who then
ended up having to work with he ended up
working with his sister again oh hey
Whitney Brown was at the time
uh really something uh-huh he's somebody
who was really one of those guys who
came on and then and then that was then
he kind of disappeared after that and I
don't know yeah he's very Hassan yeah it
was it was a great it's a great group of
but Colbert and Corelle and I was I mean
going I would be there I'd be there
about once every two weeks and then uh
and I and you just watched the two of
them and it was like [ __ ] it was like
[ __ ] you kidding me they're brilliant
yeah that that was brilliant and that
was before they were considered
brilliant right right yeah they had to
earn it yeah yeah Kyle you got that you
got South Park comedy said it was really
humming yeah back then I mean they stole
South Park and they still have the Daily
Show but these other shows were they're
supporting it too like every I mean you
I remember root of all evil this year oh
yeah that was I love because we were big
you know Greg Geraldo fans and oh yeah
that that cast of comics we had on that
show is Geraldo Patton Oswald Kathleen
Madigan wow oh
um Paul F Tompkins yeah
it was just a great group of comics and
uh you'll love this story this is
perfect this is this this will help you
when you're sitting in Los Angeles
wondering who you're gonna find to hold
the sword that you can run against
so they call we had done two seats we
had done basically two seasons and we
had finally figured out the show yeah
and I had figured out that I was never
going in the writer's room again and
made a speech about it and said that's
it's going to be best for me and best
for you you guys are really great we're
not going to be as far as I'm concerned
bringing in comics you talk to them from
the beginning and and punch up their
stuff this is not brain surgery I'm
tired of [ __ ] nitpicking about this
[ __ ]
all they're everything you write they
will get a laugh these are the best
[ __ ] Comics you can find Andy Kindler
yes uh you know we had a spectacular
group it's like there's no need for this
so we we um so we had every we finally
it figured out how to do it because the
the the the setup was kind of odd the
way in which we were we were trying to
do this it's debating two things it was
there was an odd something that we had
to figure out in terms of the math of it
the math of the comedy of it we've done
it yeah and then we get a call King from
Comedy Central going you know we uh we
really uh we want to do another season
with you but could you come back in and
uh pitch it again hmm
we've done two seasons I I went I'm not
it's like when the Yankees tried to make
Joe Torre like take a pay cut mid
contract remember that yeah that's
insane yeah so we I just said I'm not
doing it and then my two other producers
well aren't you I said you go in and
talking I'm not doing it I'm not going
in there it's so disrespect disgusting
yeah we've been on for two seasons they
put us on in the summer and I said that
was mistake that's why the the numbers
sucked well they sucked because it was
the summer and the people watching it
were the kids who were in college who
that they would get around and they'd go
[ __ ] with that we we were the show to
watch on that night right you [ __ ]
morons so it's not like you know we were
like Wednesday or third you know we were
on we were on I don't think on a Friday
or Saturday it was like a perfect shot
you know we have to go on again and the
numbers will go up there's only and I'm
sick no
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you're gonna [ __ ]
me yeah and I'm not gonna let you [ __ ]
me good for you because I would have
just been like all right I guess we have
to pitch this again I couldn't have
pitched it again wow I literally by the
about the fourth
time they were but the second third week
they were given notes I I just told the
other two producers who were really good
um I said I can't listen to them I can't
listen to their notes I'm not gonna be
here I I said it just crazy you expect
it if you're on cable to not get those
notes yeah especially after you know um
HBO had established the fact that you
might want to let your creatives do it
and figure it out yeah exactly well
that'll never be a not a thing you know
which is why you know and you guys
here's what here's what you guys really
need is a director yeah
seems like nothing great creatively
comes from committee you know on let
alone suits in a board room the smaller
the group the better oh yeah and the mob
is when it gets [ __ ] bad yep that's
true every hang is better this is
perfect we had another person it's gonna
get worse yeah I think well maybe four
is okay but once you get bigger than
four once you get bigger than four that
was generally the case I mean that was
the thing with um tough crowd another
good show yeah yeah that's the Bill Burr
and then there'd be four or five of us
on that you know that and and there
regular group but uh and and but having
Geraldo on that show was spectacular oh
yeah there was just nobody like him no
smart and biting he did his homework
always prepared and also the the master
of coming up with the substitutes for
dirty words oh really he was brilliant
interesting he was insane yeah oh I mean
literally they would say you you can't
say queef well
that's where I draw the line you can't
say this and so he would go he would go
back and two days later he'd come up
with some [ __ ] other particular
vaginal fart
yeah that's good sometimes that makes it
a better joke yeah it helps really badge
whoosh yeah
yeah tough crowd with Greg was like yeah
when he got cooking man I mean everyone
talks about that Dennis Leary moment
sure I mean it was like the ultimate
like comic versus like kind of celeb
yeah and I was like oh man it's like
justice for all kinds and not just
Comics but like the guy who's like
thinks he's too cool for school yeah and
then the guy who actually is cool and
doesn't have to [ __ ] act cool because
he just is yeah Larry's literally
wearing sunglasses and a leather jacket
in front of comics it's like you need to
hang out with more comics yeah because
they'll [ __ ] crucify you for that
[ __ ] you show up to the comedy seller
with the slightest fashion risk oh I
know that Keith Robinson's gonna be like
oh look at what we have here
okay I thought I could pull off a jean
jacket I [ __ ] up I still have that at
the Gap I'm trying something on and I'm
like I just can't I picture people
shooting on it I take it right off
Rachel Feinstein showed up one night in
a Blazer and he's like oh the assistant
D.A is here yeah you have court today
yeah that's a really picture day oh yeah
I got a convertible I've run out of car
last weekend and they upgraded me to a
convertible couldn't put the top down I
just couldn't do it I was like ah I'm
not I can't put the top down I'm too
vulnerable I'm not I'm not a cool guy so
yeah left it up I started wearing uh I
made the fashion choice to wear
um
not New York but but a bit in New York
even early on but really on the road I
started wearing suits but a coat and a
tie
and um uh in general the tide was kind
of the way it is on The Daily Show I I
really would not the type that was a
thing that I always believed in you
don't you don't bring it up it's like
you because if you it's to me it was the
way I wore it when I was working in a
government office right it was the one
it was the way in which I could wear
that I had to wear a tie and it had to
be knotted but I wouldn't [ __ ] you I'm
not taking it though so I would but I
would wear the I would try to look nicer
than anybody in the room because I knew
it might shut them the [ __ ] up because
they'd be stuck trying to figure out
where
he's saying this ship but where did he
get that how do you get those clothes
right saying that crap so in a sense it
was like uh yeah you see I'm doing okay
you [ __ ] right things right I'm a
professional and also it was and I
initially would talk about it I'd say
you know you wear a coat and tie you can
say anything you [ __ ] want and that's
why you listen to these [ __ ] who
come on TV who are like your Senator and
[ __ ] yeah because they're wearing a tie
a trumpet that's why I'm wearing a tie
it's very smart I mean it really is
because but it is I mean the dry
cleaning which drive me crazy oh yeah
but that's it's a small price to pay
and you don't have to think about what
you're wearing just throw the suit on
and move on a suit does look badass on
stage it does yeah and it was it was it
was really the biggest pain in the ass
was never dry cleaning was dragging
those [ __ ] things around because you
wanted you had to have at least a couple
of sports coats right God damn it but a
suit is nice but a wrinkly suit is worse
than a t-shirt
yeah yeah you look like you're one of
the losers in Glengarry Glen Rose
coffee's for closers uh so I've just
rewatched that movie over the summer
it's [ __ ] it's a great movie so good
damn it yeah he's an [ __ ] but do you
know him I was uh I wrote plays I know
it was in a Yale right yeah drama school
yeah oh
I call it drama school and um so you
knew him a little bit
he was a a tutor there a mentor he was
not a mentor but he was hired to
foreign
playwrights that they brought in that
were basically to work with the the the
the playwrights at the school and one of
them was David Mammoth and he was just
an [ __ ] yeah and he was my age so it
was really it was like you're sending in
a guy my age to tell me and he would say
to us this is you know you know in order
to and he was right but you know you
don't tell us this we're really there to
kind of learn how to write so you know
in order to get your work done you need
to spend at least two thousand dollars a
year sending out your scripts Jesus and
it's more [ __ ] broke yeah because
there's a [ __ ] fortune to come to
this [ __ ] place and you were gonna
where were you supposed to put the money
together yeah and then he would quote
Russian oh boy and uh and and he would
and so my girlfriend at the time said
you speak Russian and he goes no she
comes with your puberty you're an asset
yeah damn it was he was kind of a dick
and it was uh it was this very kind
there was an arrogance to him dealing
with us here's your reading list well we
don't have to read the books okay it was
kind of like
my friend he want you to read
you're gonna go in a bowl of slavsky you
heard of Bola slavsky yeah stanislavski
he's in the same school as Stanislaus
okay
because we know books on acting yeah ah
you know oh that's like a method right
yeah yeah right you know it's the uh
it's a way in which to go at it and I
can't remember what Paul islowski was so
[ __ ] I was so angry that it was on
the reading list and my friend to her
but my other friend tore the reading
list up in his face it was like we were
really pissed yeah you know it was just
and the other guys were pretty you know
I'm going to read you he read his stuff
right we're supposed to read our stuff
he's reading his stuff to us that's all
I got to say yeah that really cuts to
the chase yeah edit those other two
who's who is cool like did anyone any
big playwrights come in there nobody I
mean nobody that you would know Arthur
copit who you wouldn't know but who
wrote some really great no Dad Poor Dad
mamas hung in the closet and I'm feeling
so sad title alone great yeah so and
then there's uh
um the other guys I don't think you
babaletti wouldn't know you wouldn't
know the some of the others if they were
really uh Robert Penn Warren was there
the one who wrote All the King's Men but
not to teach playwriting but he was
so old it was just you're going God
Robert Ben Warren this would be great
yeah one of my great books one of the
greatest books and you went to that
first kind of seminar he's teaching he
going oh boy I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
last 10 minutes
what's he saying I mean he's really
genius but it was you really had to you
had to care a lot more than I did yeah
well isn't comedy so much more fun than
playwriting oh yeah but not you know
what's funny it's uh uh people it's it's
people you know comedy is tough
playwriting stuffer oh really yeah well
the isolation's got to be tough right
everything about it I mean think about
it you know we create our own realities
up there it's just us and we can you
know we're and there's a certain bit of
uh you know you learn there's a certain
bit of like not magic magic but there's
a certain bit of [ __ ] to the thing
that yeah once you kind of that you
could live on certain Comics do but yeah
but at least what you're you know the
the tools you turned into save your
[ __ ] ass yeah but playwriting Jesus
you know because if you think they come
after you as a comic you you write
something then really
oh [ __ ] your you know imagine you know
you go there you write something and
then it ends up they write about it in
the New York Times and say that you're a
piece of [ __ ] wow you know but it's a
play it's fiction yeah but they don't
care that count is more easily offended
who do you think's gonna get more easily
offended a writer for the New Yorker or
some guy to strip mall in Missouri you
know yeah yeah but you devoted three
years of your life to something then
they come in and say you know uh it
didn't work yeah that's the other it's
not like just you know they they don't
let you know it's one thing to go into a
club and they don't laugh it's another
thing that that somebody writes down
yeah everybody hated you uh it was right
I had a I had I had everybody hated you
was a good title
my favorite was um I got a review in
something called New West which was the
the new the New York Magazine of the
West Coast of California so New West had
this thing where they uh they wanted to
they reviewed a play of mine and it was
it was not a good production at all
there were real problems with it and um
I like try to get early on tried to get
one of the actors just fired because it
was going to kill the play it was the
center of the play it was good I needed
I needed Broderick Crawford in the part
I needed some [ __ ] mean heavy and I
got like uh you know some [ __ ] the
guy was wanted to be liked right like no
I can't you can't stand on stage with a
rifle in your hand doing stuff and
talking about you know being nice about
yeah I need you to blow people up so so
the thing didn't it just didn't work but
the review I got was is that it began
with um first Let It Be noted that none
of Lewis Black's plays should ever be
produced in the state of California
again
wow kicked out of the state kicked out
of the state Jesus and that was and and
by that point I'd been through enough
stuff that I could handle it a bit but
it but and one of the reasons I can
handle those who uh that I must if I got
this guy so upset I'm doing something
right yeah that's true you know and that
he didn't and it was the one thing about
plus you got people it's the same thing
if you're going in to pitch a project
and you've got somebody credit sitting
across from the table from you that has
never done what you do yeah and that's
what you're dealing with a lot of the
times with these critics who you you
know who who also they they don't you
know if they know anything about you
know they should be able to separate the
acting from the writing from interacting
that's what their job is but it never
they never [ __ ] know they'll never
know it like we know it yeah yeah but
what a psycho to write that down and
publish it that's insane what's the name
of the guy in the sweet smell of success
every critic still thinks they're that
[ __ ] guy yes they still think like
I'll destroy you in my column and you're
like yeah it's 2022 dude yeah right you
don't have the pull you thought you had
yes and now I can find you you know
where you live
[ __ ] that guy that's like so harsh
they can hide behind their little pen
and their magazine in their newspaper no
I'm going right on Facebook and Zillow
and on GPS and I did a show with Mark
Lynn Baker at the public theater that
both of us
the audience went nuts every night it
was a short shows 55 minutes so and it's
one of those shows I described as your
your home for three hours before you
realize you didn't like it because it's
so short we didn't take up your time
you're in the bar by nine yes best show
ever that's great and is theater dead
not dead but now it's all Mamma Mia
Broadway's in trouble because of covet I
mean he's got problems there's there's
some real there's stuff it's like stand
up there's some really great stuff
that's fomenting it's over here and then
there's some just you know we're going
to be dealing with that other stuff
Phantom is finally finished uh-huh and
dear Evan Hansen which was kind of
shocking because that was a hit that was
like the hottest ticket in town a couple
years ago and now it's just dead but if
you go to strange Loop is the The
Unbelievable it's I'm gonna just say it
it is unfucking believable okay it's a
strange loop it's a musical Iraq that's
a good wreck I mean it is it's one of
these things that it got the I think it
won the Tony yeah he got it for best uh
best it's I think it's his the way um
Hamilton is great and it's really
remarkable this one is is is also that
good but it's good in the sense of this
guy gets so much off of his chest
the two of you I think will go nuts I
think you'll you'll get a kick out of it
because he just he he really goes after
like
um you know this thing where we go
through our careers and get the [ __ ]
kicked out of us and he goes through
every moment of it and and does some of
it musically right and his parents
really are and he's you know he's gay
and he's he's overweight and it brings
in all those problems but it's done
really blisteringly funny is not it's
unbelievable oh wow all right all right
it's really it's it's I it's one of the
few things that I've said to people uh
you know go to it and they've they've
liked it and yeah and and if and if you
and if and all right let's get something
straight right now those of you are
listening if this is the kind of thing
you're gonna go again it upset me you if
you get upset about [ __ ] you don't go
you normally do not push anything but
that's well worth the time and energy
and everything all right I love it wait
I'll stop go back down I just want to
read that uh up a little right there
strange Loop is the big black and
queer-ass Great American Music for all
musical for all that's a hell of a
review this guy did not write yours do
it no he did but it is worth it and he
is really funny all right
um and Relentless oh it's one of those
things you go it's that thing where you
kind of go where somebody does five
Toppers you know and he does like 12
Toppers in a song you go God he's got to
stop now yeah and you're really laughing
and he doesn't stop and it's partly
because it's so bitter and I think you
guys enjoy that yes oh yeah really
something I want to feel something
all right bring it on Louis do you have
any uh pet peeves everything
as you can see I like this musical
because this guy is so [ __ ] Angry Kid
she's straight
um I I got a lot of things that bothered
me I if they don't stop taking this
[ __ ] and it's everybody and it
bothers everybody and it just has got to
stop you put you pay for somebody to be
on the phone and answer the phone and
direct you to who to talk to now and you
don't have a machine that goes what is
your problem is it a [ __ ] you my problem
is in a b or c my problem isn't is it is
it uh something technical yes could
explain it in just a few I can't explain
it that's the worst [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
because well press one at least we're
getting somewhere this is now very vague
or I'm just speaking I always curse into
it too and I wonder if cursing they have
like some robot sensor to push you
further back on hold
um this guy sucks but I've had that
paranoid but I don't care anymore yeah
I'd rather be back there and I because
what I find is if I continue to yell
eventually it goes
you kind of can't deal with the unit
essentially attention to somebody
squeaky wheel yeah I always wanted the
zero doesn't work no you're the operator
yeah that used to be the move yeah they
got hip to that
I always wonder if a celebrity's ever
called in to yell at customer service
like a musician and then their song
comes on when they're on hold I've
always wanted that's gotta have happened
at some point I don't think I don't
think Springsteen's doing his own I
don't think Stevie Nicks
all right
yeah that drives me nuts that there's a
lot that really makes me crazy I mean
that's a good one uh it's gotten to the
point with a lot of things where it's
kind of like
stupid makes me comment there ought to
be and it has to be done uh this uh you
we whether we like it or not and I know
this is a stupid thing but it's true my
you have to teach Civics whether anybody
likes it or not you have to actually
teach did you ever have to take Civics I
did yeah did you yeah see yeah and that
explains a lot of your work
Lewis Black everyone
thank you is is there uh I I want to ask
uh well first off is there anything you
want to plug is there anything like tour
dates you got Indiana coming up I've got
uh yeah I've got if you go to Lewis
black.com and can tell you more but I'll
be in uh this week it's uh it's Warren
and uh Dayton and um and uh in Carmel
Indiana Fort Wayne Indiana and then we
go to uh Albuquerque in Tucson and then
we go to Phoenix and then we're coming
into Riverside
very nice it's one of the few places
they didn't allow you to smoke outside
early on God did not enrage me talk
about being a peeve and then uh San
Francisco and Palm Desert be 3 000
degrees San Diego Los Angeles Eugene all
right you are out there yeah I'm gonna
be uh doing that I don't get back until
and then uh and then the other thing I'd
like to plug which is do you guys like
um
did you ever read uh Vonnegut yeah oh
yeah of course yeah well you wonder I
mean you you know but most people do but
it seem to be as nuts as you two but
most people do yeah and uh but I'm I I'm
there's a Vonnegut Museum now in uh in
library uh in um in in Indianapolis
Indiana oh nice and due to circumstances
that seem to be problematic for them
they've been there uh the chairman of
the board of their uh no way yeah I am
that's amazing that is really cool it is
I said are you sure yes yes for sure are
you really sure oh yes we really want
look I'm just telling you uh you have to
sign something since I don't know what
I'm doing that I can't go to jail
because I really don't know what's up
but it was mainly to help them fundraise
and it's I said if you really think I
can attract money great because it's
it's it's a great if you're ever out if
you're when you're out there working
it's great I'm down it's a really good
it's got it like stuff that he uh wrote
It's all sorts of things that um really
are interesting and uh there's a letter
that's worth seeing just from the
standpoint there's a letter sitting
there that he wrote to his father
his father wrote to him either I think
just before he went to war
uh or during that time frame and
Vonnegut never opened it and in his will
he said he wanted no one to open it oh
and it just sits there that's worth
going to the museum wow because you
never walk out of the museum thinking
right what the [ __ ] was that you know
and there's some really great stuff
there and they do some great work and
span
books Annapolis it's downtown
Indianapolis yes wow all right and it's
banned book books week and uh
Slaughterhouse Five has been banned in a
ton of places
isn't that great yeah by the way
whenever you say a book is like is it
banned that is reason to read it yeah
like when they said you can't read Mouse
oh yeah you can't read about the [ __ ]
Holocaust yeah I know that is like yeah
that's a level away from Holocaust
there's a nude cartoon yeah a nude
[ __ ] Mouse yeah maybe it wasn't a
mouse was it a mouse yeah I think it was
a mouse it was a naked mouse yeah well
some people just don't like fiction
but it's well worth the uh but it really
is unbelievable I'll definitely check it
out next time now finally I won't be
dreading Indianapolis as much as no it's
well worth no it's worth the and if you
go let me know because uh you know he's
got I've got some suck there man yeah I
can get you I can get you two free
lattes
by the way we're drinking coconut we
didn't even say we're drinking this week
coconut uh milk latte never had it
pretty good it's not bad it's not a bad
it's I just wanted it because I [ __ ]
I can't drink in the air I drink wine
normally and I can't drink in the
afternoons
yeah but next time we'll get you some
really good wine we'll do this at night
we'll make it a night up if we do it at
night I can I'll do it and the other
thing I wanted to say before I left was
is that I don't know if you knew that
they uh the thing we're going to talk
about at the beginning that uh I got
these emails we did a new t-shirt the
T-shirt oh I did hear about this comedy
yes yes and there's the T-shirt yeah I
got a similar t-shirt and yours has an
exclamation yeah yeah mine is more fun
it is comedy it is no and mine's more
dry [ __ ] you and the E is actually
turned around the other way I don't know
why it's presented like that okay and uh
but
um and I wanted you to know because I
got these three emails and then about I
mean three tweets about it and these and
one guy had said You [ __ ] old man
[ __ ] you steal this guy you've got
nothing left but to steal some really
brilliant young Comics ah [ __ ]
T-shirt idea and I just wanted you to
know we we we would not have thought of
it no you know it's great and I'm sorry
I wrote that yeah and I really feel
badly and I'll get you I'll get you two
of those we should wear those
yeah yeah we'll swap and I love should
because then I'd wear yours it's because
it's really it's ludicrous and then but
we were gonna we're gonna stop selling
it online oh good you know so and mine
are five years are five cents cheaper
than mine
that's like remember that Tom Green
sketch where he he would follow around
undercutters Pizza yeah yeah a guy would
be like he'd follow a pizza delivery guy
around with his own pizza and he would
try to undercut and he said what
toppings yeah he pulled all the toppings
and he would just charge like five bucks
less that's a great guy I also have
queef nice and there's comedy I almost
sold the against baby oh you have it in
black and white too oh yeah oh wow so I
already tell you Dimitri Martin wore
comedy on his special with the no
exclamation and no period so we're all
in the same ball well who did Dimitri
Martin has has comedy on his yeah but he
just wore it on on a special it's not
his merch I don't think I bet it is that
son of a [ __ ] you know him too he's
always like that sneaking around yeah
he's a slippery one that Greek he was
also one oh that's right that's right we
got to get him on here he's terrific big
fan he's coming up oh great yeah he's
great he is really really good but that
guy but we're going to stop selling it
because I felt badly about no you could
sell it are you sure yeah yeah I mean
you got the period I got the exclamation
okay I feel like it is I feel like and I
think we approached the whole [ __ ]
differently yeah
yeah I Hawk mine after the show
personally do you no I uh I I actually
we have not been selling stuff we're
gonna start again well let's all start
all right well I'll get you one of these
please I have a shirt I'm thinking of
selling I'm worried people aren't going
to wear it it's the again I've I have a
joke in my special about how people wear
shirts that say like [ __ ] racism and
just like all right like do we have to
wear obvious beliefs on a shirt so the
joke is basically like uh I'm gonna wear
a shirt this is against baby rape and uh
and people like why are you wearing that
I say are you four baby right you know
so I want to make a shirt do we have a
picture of it Matt because now people
are just selling it now people are
making money at money because I posted I
posted a graphic of it saying should I
sell this and now I'm getting people
sending me other people are selling your
idea let's see yeah Sam again you gotta
get on that no can you pull it up
[Applause]
that's great would people wear that I
would wear that you'd weren't against
baby rapes hell yeah
look if it's there they'll wear it my
mom saw it and it's also the picture is
what makes it yeah my mom saw it and she
said I'm so ashamed of you for this and
I was just I think I'm gonna call my
next two of the jokes that have set my
mother tour and that upset I told that
to her and that upset her and I was like
I got it doing that you gotta do it but
against baby right that is you know it's
it's a good cause the cause I care about
yeah exactly now elderly rape I'm four
yeah of course but yeah you know you
could put a the bottom in case they were
whining it caused to care about you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
remember that was a big thing on like a
bumper sticker would say like if you
have any comments here's the number
1-800 [ __ ] you that was a fun gag
88. you know when you had no internet
you had to just stare at a bumper
sticker for entertainment
but hey in the words of uh Kurt Vonnegut
make no mistake we're all just here to
fart around Mark Where Are You Gonna Be
man I'm all over the play I don't know
when this comes out probably the week
after next right royal royal oak great
yeah I love Royal Oak yep Music Theater
Roxanne theater in Pittsburgh Orlando
Improv uh the Englert uh Rococo and
Lincoln Nebraska Coco's great oh really
wait there a million years ago wow
Pantages and mini app perfect more and
uh Seattle just added revolution in
Portland uh Neptune in Seattle the Vogue
in
vancouver.com doing the Wilbur a lot of
fun stuff uh Omaha Funny Bone stand up
live Lexington Kentucky New Brunswick
Oklahoma City Springfield Missouri Fort
Wayne Indiana Kansas City Tacoma Spokane
building up new material here watch the
special on Netflix same time tomorrow
and and buy our whiskey yes Bodega
catwhiskey.com is that your whiskey it's
ours yeah nice take a bottle yeah if you
do you drink whiskey at all yeah oh take
a bottle yeah
all right well thank you thanks for
listening you're the man that was great
guys that was fun thank you I had a
great time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and make it you I was feeling dangerous
[Music]
[Music]